talk is on abstract value iteration for
hierarchical url and
this was published in ai stats 2021 so
it's
quite recent um let me start with
a quick introduction to hierarchical
let us start with an uh motivating
motivating example where there is
a maze of rooms and there's a robot that
is trying to navigate this maze of rooms
uh let's say periodically you could
observe the state of the robot which is
simply the position
in r2 and let's say you can control the
robot by giving it velocity commands
and our goal is to learn a policy to go
from the blue region to the green region
and we apriori do not know
which rooms have a doorway between them
and which rooms do not so
this is something that you have to
figure out by
by exploring in the environment and
if you try to use regular
state-of-the-art d-parallel algorithms
for this
problem uh they usually do not work
because
firstly this is a large state space to
explore and
secondly most algorithms will give you a
solution in which the robot
will go to the room in the top right uh
corner from which it cannot really make
any progress
um and hierarchy coloral is supposed to
work in such scenarios where there is
this
long horizon task and and it requires a
lot of exploration
the idea behind hierarchical rl is
typically you have a hierarchy of
policies
for simplicity let's say there is uh
there are two two levels of policies a
high level policy pi hatch which
maps uh the current state uh to the next
intermediate goal
say s prime and there's a low level
policy that takes
uh the current state s and s prime and
outputs
a concrete action right and the high
level policy is only involved
every few steps so that you know the
horizon at the high level is
reduced effectively and this works
uh in in many cases because it uh
it decomposes the problem into two
simpler rl problems
and and uh there's also better
exploration at the high level
but unfortunately for this particular
example and many examples where
you really have to plan a
plan at the high level it doesn't quite
work and
if you apply existing rld parallel
hierarchical algorithms
they tend to go to the same local
optimum
so the idea behind our work is that
many environments including this one
have a lot of structure in them and
you might know that this structure
exists a priori
and you you want to use the structure
and the environment in order to
explore better right so
this structure is encoded in the form of
abstract states
so an abstract state is simply a subset
of the state space
and there's also an abstract graph for
example
in this setting each room might be an
abstract state of its own
and and you might know beforehand that
there are these rooms
and abstract graphs simply
is a graph with abstract states as
vertices and it just denote
what high level actions you want to
consider for example
in this setting there is an edge between
7 and 8 although there is no doorway
between them because you don't know that
there is no doorway between them
but nonetheless you know that they are
probably next to each other
right now
suppose this sort of information is
available to you
uh beforehand then uh the eye level idea
is simple
first you learn um one policy for each
edge in the
abstract graph that takes the system
from any state in the source abstract
state
to some state in the target abstract
state
and once you learn these policies you
sort of figure out what policies to use
and how to combine them uh using a high
level planner right
so the main questions that we we answer
in this paper
are how to plan uh using the learned
policies
as well as under what conditions on
these abstract states can we
can we guarantee something about the
final uh learn policy
before moving on i'd like to give a
brief introduction to options
options framework is popular in rl for
representing these high-level actions
right in our case high-level actions are
these policies that take you between
rooms let's say
so an option is simply an extended
action where
it's represented as a tuple pi comma i
comma beta
where pi is simply a policy and i is a
set of states from which you can
start using this option and beta uh
maps every state to to the probability
that the option terminates in that state
so when you execute this option
uh the policy pi will be used
until uh you terminate right at which
point you will be required to choose
another option
and let's say you have an mdp where
where you also have trained these
options
these high-level actions and you would
like to
find the policy that is best with
respect to these options right you want
to find
a high level policy that maps every
state to an option
that is best with respect to the rewards
uh with respect to discounted some
reward right
uh and this can be done using uh value
iteration
as shown in prior work um we just have
to
uh define the transition probabilities
and the rewards appropriately
for example the reward of taking and
taking
an option o at state s is simply the
expected discounted sum reward until the
option terminates
and the transition probabilities
probabilities are not
uh are not essentially probabilities
they are
time discounted so uh the probability
going to state s prime and taking option
o from state
s is simply sum over all times gamma
raised to t which is
this count factor multiplied by uh
the probability probability that the
option terminates
in state s prime given that it
terminates after exactly t steps
and multiply by the probability that the
option terminates after exactly t steps
right once you define this you can
define
these this these bellman equations
which look very similar to regular value
iteration
um so all you need to
do is find a fixed point of a fixed
point
solution to these equations
and in the end the optimal option policy
or high level policy is simply one
that takes that maps
a state to the option that maximizes
this q value
uh q of s comma o which is which is
defined by these equations
uh this is all good so for now
so in our framework we have options for
every edge so
for every edge we have this tuple where
a pi is
trained to take the system from s delta
to s tilde prime
and the initial set is simply s tilde
and beta is given by uh you
terminate if you if you end up
in a state that's
in any other abstract state except s
tilde and zero otherwise
right you terminate as soon as you reach
some other abstract state and
in order to compute a high level plan
you can simply use value iteration uh
but in in the case of continuous state
spaces
um performing value iteration
might involve function approximators
but rather we would want to do value
iteration of planning just
on the abstract states right so in order
to do that we define these
uh transition analogs of transition
probabilities and rewards
for the abstract uh setting
right and we have two sets of such
quantities uh the one
denoting infimum and one denoting as a
premium
so uh let me quickly go over the interim
definitions
so the transition probability of going
from s tilde to s tilde prime on taking
uh option o is simply infimum over
all states in s tilde of uh
of the discounted uh time discounted
transition probability
that option o terminates in the abstract
state s delta prime when
when it's taken at state s
and uh the r tilde of
uh s tilde and an option o is simply the
infimum over all states
in in the abstract state as tilde of
the expected discounted sum reward
off of the option o
when started in state s right and
supremes are defined
appropriately now you can define uh
you can take the same equations uh the
same uh
belmont equations that you had except
that replace
the state space with the abstract state
space and
you have one one set of equations for
for inf and one for
uh supreme and you will end up computing
uh two sets of values uh v in f and v
soup for each uh abstract state
and and what do these values give us
right we want to analyze what these
values
give us and and can we do anything with
just this information right
so in order to do that we first define
uh define these errors uh
epsilon t and epsilon r epsilon t is
nothing but the worst case error between
t sub and t
and and epsilon r is similarly the worst
case error between
uh the rewards uh supreme and phenomenon
and um what we can show
is that this procedure like the bellman
equations are in fact
uh contractions and hence our procedure
which we call robust abstract value
iteration
converges if
epsilon t is small enough if the error
in
transition probabilities is small enough
and
we also have that the true best value of
a state s
is contained between this infimum
and supremum values of of its
corresponding abstract state
and furthermore if we choose the high
level of
high level policy to simply pick the
option that maximizes q
in q star n
then we can
obtain some bounds on the sub optimality
of this high level policy compared to
the best high level policy which is
roster
right so uh
and i want to uh point out for those
familiar with abstract interpretation
what we are essentially doing is
performing abstract interpretation over
value iteration
where the abstract domain is simply in
the interval domain
right and so that's good and
what we get from the theory is
that you want abstract states where um
every state within an abstract state is
similar in terms of
our transitions and works in order for
this to work
and and now the theory actually doesn't
assume that the abstract states cover
the
state space so they are uh more like sub
gold regions
rather than abstract states so uh
for example there are two choices here
of abstract states where the first one
denotes
uh each abstract state being a small
region in
the center of each room and the second
one denotes
an abstract state being the doorway
regions
and these tend to work better because uh
they are sort of smaller
and probably the states within them are
similar right
the second choice is a bit special
because
uh they form what are known as
bottlenecks so
any policy that takes you from three to
nine
after the blue region to the green
region has to go through
uh some of these uh abstract states
and in in that case in that special case
we have some stronger guarantees
but uh it might be hard for to know
apiary what these bottleneck states are
so
it's not really necessary to have them
to be bottlenecks but
you get stronger guarantees if they are
so now how do we train options right how
do we train these transitions that take
you between different
abstract states uh we use standard
reinforcement learning
and these are potentially shorter
horizon problems that are
simpler than the whole uh problem and
it's probably easier to train
but there is a small issue here which is
that
you are the planning algorithm requires
that
the options that you train work well for
all states
equally well for all states uh in in any
given abstract state right
for example in in this state
one let's say that you look you're
looking at a state a pusher in the
middle of the doorway
it is much easier to construct a policy
that
reaches four as opposed to
some state in in the corner of the
doorway right
which requires a lot of maneuvering and
training a policy that works well in the
worst case
is might be hard and it might require a
lot of samples
so but what we can what we really want
is the option to work well on the stairs
that you actually reach for example when
you are taking
the abstract edge from three to one
if you could only train on a train on
the states reached
uh when you are taking this policy
that is good enough right so we use this
observation to propose
a hierarchical rl algorithm
that we call alternating abstract value
iteration
or aavi so what we do in alternating
abstract value iteration
is uh we maintain a distribution
uh for every abstract state we maintain
a distribution over concrete states
in the uh abstract state
and uh we iteratively do uh
do a few things first we use
distributions to learn policies uh or
options that take you between different
abstract states
and then uh we estimate the transition
probability rewards for those options
and compute a higher level plan using
our abstract value iteration procedure
and once we compute a plan we execute
this plan and see what states are
reached
and use these states to update these
distributions
and we keep repeating until uh until
for for a fixed number of iterations and
you can also show that this converges
under some no regret assumptions but
i will not go into the details here
um so what we do uh
we actually evaluate this hierarchical
rl algorithm
on a bunch of environments the first set
of environments are these rooms
environments where you simply control
the velocity of the robot
and we also consider more challenging
environments which are these
maze-like environments where uh the
robot is actually not this simple
it is the mojoko and which sort of is
slightly harder to control
and what we show is that
we can learn better policies with fewer
samples right here the plots
indicate learning curves where x axis is
the
number of samples and y-axis is the
probability of reaching the goal
and the blue line denotes our
our approach and we compare against a
beanie
uh state-of-the-art colorado
algorithms and and the blue line denotes
uh
the same approach without alternation
right it is essentially
uh learning all options once uh and and
tries to
plan and as noted earlier uh it requires
a lot more
uh samples to learn because it needs to
learn these robust
policies for transitions
and we also have a study on
on comparing different uh sets of
abstract states for the room's
environment
the doorways which are the bottleneck
set of abstract stage seems to perform
the best
uh followed by uh the centers of the
rooms
and and finally uh the
the case where you consider the entire
rooms abstract
stage
[Music]
here the y-axis denotes the discounted
reward so
it's higher when you reach reach the
goal faster but if you actually look at
the probabilities it's
uh roughly the they roughly converge to
one for
both both room centers and doorways so
uh yeah so in certain cases
it's it's fine if the abstract states
are not model next
and uh our approach still requires
an expert to
to give you this additional information
and
we sort of experimented with what we can
do
to eliminate this this assumption and
we have some studies on using randomly
generated abstract states
where we randomly pick a bunch of points
and then
consider small regions around them as
abstract states
and then
we run our we run our algorithms on
these and
we still can show that we can learn
reasonably good policies
so to conclude uh we proposed two
algorithms
one is a planning algorithm uh which has
theoretical bounds
on sub optimality and we propose a
practical hierarchical
rl algorithm that works quite well in
practice
and some future work includes this
generation of good
abstract states maybe from specification
languages or
or just from rewards by exploring and
and also many of these options might be
similar might be doing similar things to
each other so
it might be good to work on ways to
identify these these different options
that are similar and try to share
policies across them
in order to improve sample efficiency
um that's it for my talk uh thank you
for listening
and thanks for inviting me to give a
talk here
and if there is time i would be happy to
take questions
thank you very much um are there
questions
so if you have a question you can simply
unmute yourself and ask
or you can write in the chat so maybe i
can start with a very simple question so
if i just think of the non-probabilistic
reactive synthesis setting
uh does this kind of does this give you
a way of doing abstract reactive
synthesis right where you kind of
learn strategies for you know some
particular things and then you put them
together
in a way so you know you're working in
the world of mark of decision processes
but does this
imply something about hierarchical
reactive synthesis
um i mean the theory does hold
yeah i mean in the pure automata all the
theory were
right i mean it doesn't like any fixed
deterministic process is also an
also an ndp uh
but i think um what
this is essentially saying is
is if you could identify uh sort of
key points that you want to uh visit
during your
uh during your execution
then that is good enough and you you
have some sort of
[Music]
you can abstract away the problem into a
much smaller
simpler finite state problems even if
your underlying thing is continuous
but if your underlying thing is finite
even i think
you can still do this if if the state
space is large you could
you might want to reduce it to a smaller
state space by doing this sort of
approach
but that setting is not something that
we studied and
yeah and maybe it's a good direction for
future work
thank you other questions
so if i may just ask a follow-up so
these abstract states are
so you said that at this point you kind
of
so the user has to provide them yeah but
in your experiments you
just tried some random points as
intermediate abstract points is that
right uh not in these not in the primary
experiments but we
also considered randomly generated
rooms environments i see so in the
primary experiments essentially the
structure of the problem the rooms
already gave you a natural mapping to
abstract states correct
yeah and in in this case of ant we just
we sort of know what the environment
looks like so we just
pick a bunch of points in certain key
areas
and you use those yeah
i see very nice
are there any other questions
if not let me thank kishore again on
behalf
of all the organizers and the attendees
for the seminar and this brings us to
the end of the seminar series
uh thank you everyone for coming and
thank you to all the speakers for
uh coming and giving a talk here okay
that's it and have a good rest of the
evening
thanks bye bye